[Music]
Selena Gomez Jennifer Lawrence and more
we're running down the best dressed
celebs of the week with all the deets on
what they wore
[Music]
first up Selena Gomez in London on
Monday leaving her coach event 25 year
old looked oh so chic in this sheer
black number it's the coach 1941
embellished penguin shirt dress part of
the brand's resort 2018 collection it
retails for 995 bucks those Western
inspired lace-up boots are also coached
but they are pre fall 2018 and not yet
available to buy you know it's a totally
different style next up Kyah Gerber also
in London on Monday at the Fashion
Awards the 16 year old stunned in this
sky-blue two-piece set with ruffled
detailing and crystal embellishments
it's from Ralph and Russo's spring 2018
ready-to-wear collection and costs
almost 40 gram her matching heels also
buy Ralph and Russo retail for $1,700
she paired the look with jewels by
Masika Paris including a double ring in
white gold it's just over 7,000 bucks
yeah it's amazing
check out margot robbie at the premiere
of her new flick i Tanya in Los Angeles
on Tuesday this is Versace and I'm
really enjoying my Michelle Pfeiffer
Scarface moments with the hair and
makeup so yeah the dress is Versace
but it's custom inspired by the fashion
house's a tribute collection so there's
no price the strappy black heels are
Jimmy Joo and usually go for 795 bucks
the sleek black clutch shawl so Jimmy
Choo isn't available anymore but similar
bags sell for 1,350 bucks
honestly being here tonight I mean it's
the Egyptian theater and the middle of
Hollywood it's it's quite surreal and
lastly Jennifer Lawrence at The
Hollywood Reporter is women in
entertainment breakfast in LA on
Wednesday oh well that's very nice the
27 year olds pretty in pink in this
delicate yet perfect dress it's from
philosophy spring 2018 collection it'll
cost you two thousand six hundred and
ninety five dollars
Jayla added these black Nicholas
Kirkwood pumps to the feminine look
they retail for just under 700 bucks so
a huge owner
all right guys which star gets your vote
for Best Dressed this week let me know
in the comments section or over on
Twitter and I'll see you later
[Music]
you